we have the story from NBC News it's
kind of crazy drone strikes hit Moscow
in first attack on Russian Russia's
Russian capitals residential areas since
Ukraine War Began once again no one
knows exactly who's responsible Russia
of course says it's the Kiev regime
attacking civilian targets while the
West says that it's Russian false flag
intended to bolster public support for
war in Russia here's why I think that's
less likely the attack was on a wealthy
area of Moscow if you attack poor people
you generate support for war if you
attack rich people the rich people come
after rich people in The Establishment
Elite say like hey stop this our wealth
is being destroyed because of it it's
also possible the idea to attack the
rich people because the rich people will
then be like we want war now but the
rich
people were always part of the regime
the political establishment in Russia so
they're typically in line already yeah
that's a good point I mean if the elite
are going to pull off some kind of false
flag it would make much more sense for
them to go after people who are lower
status and don't have as much power to
fight back against them
yeah world war three hmm
um
I don't know I think that uh what our
entire media needs to do is speak about
this as aggressively as possible without
considering the consequences
what do you mean no I'm being I'm being
facetious because that's what David I
mean that's what they've been doing
right we were talking about this earlier
when Lindsey Graham like a year and a
half ago got on the BBC and literally
called for Putin's assassination I mean
people come after figures in New Media
for saying something slightly offensive
say well these content creators just
aren't responsible enough I mean
an American politician was on television
calling for the assassination of the
leader of a nation which is armed with
nuclear weapons and that was just
allowed to happen yeah I think it's I
mean we've uh the the media and
political classes rhetoric surrounding
this has been insanely irresponsible
thank you responsible it's important to
be responsible even right now us talking
about this because there's a lot of
people listening and this is like
sensitive you know I I don't think it's
a false flag but then a dozen or so
drones
attacked civilians drone Warfare 21st
century Warfare we see the tip of the
spear right now
attack civilians I think it makes sense
that Kiev did this more so than Russia
false flagged it or some could have been
some independent if Russia was going to
do right trying to Fan the Flames of war
between all factions yeah but I feel
like if Russia was going to do a false
flag they wouldn't Target their Elites
and it would be more sophisticated than
a few drones that failed to do any real
damage yeah the real issue I think is
that Kiev wants to send Terror to the
civilians and destabilize public opinion
definitely I think that's what it is
it's also like kind of a tip or tat
thing because they've been shelling
different parts of like Ukraine as well
including like I don't think it stood
for Tad I think it's more so you want to
force the enemy to retreat to start you
put them up put them on defense instead
of offense but if this is legitimate
attack or whether or not even if it's
not I think we're now moving very
seriously close towards a nuclear war
because Vladimir Putin said he would use
nukes if there was an existential threat
to Russia and now Russian civilians are
being attacked and the United States has
done nothing to promote diplomacy he's
not going to lose that war right he has
nukes and he's not the kind of guy
that's like well I would win but I just
don't want to use my news
it's not how it works dude when when the
when the USSR fell with the United
States promised is that we would not
expand NATO an inch Eastward and all we
have done is expand NATO Eastward that
entire time and
I'm not saying what Putin has done is by
any means good but what I am saying is
our failure to behave diplomatically on
the global stage
Bears some responsibility for What's
Happening Here Right you can't just put
this all on crazy bad Russian man dude
the United States had a duty to behave
responsibly on the foreign stage and we
consistently have not I remember
watching like maybe like almost 10 years
ago
um I think we might have been like a
vice vice piece I don't remember what it
was but I was watching years and years
ago uh it was Putin speaking saying like
the West is aggressing the West has all
these new positions outside of out of
Russia now and that that's only born to
be true now that he's actually in the
situation that we are in the situation
it's just
yeah it's it's so weird it's so weird
that we that we are finally here
Engineers since then so do you think
this is like a fold over of fear of like
the of the the Soviet Union like like no
I'm not blaming Hillary like whoever but
like people from that generation are
like they're actually afraid of a of the
Soviet Union communism in Ukraine many
people are yeah well I think that what
this I mean
Russia his in the 20th century faced
what two up to this point three serious
existential crises in the United States
and Germany has been involved with all
of them and so NATO which is basically
the United States and Germany starts
inching closer and closer towards
Russia's borders I mean it was there was
no sensitivity on our part and saying
okay even if our intentions are good
let's pretend that they were and we can
guarantee that our intentions were good
maybe we need to be very careful and
sensitive about how we go about this so
that a hot war between Russia and
Ukraine doesn't begin but
no we did what we did we we mercilessly
ridiculed and insulted Russia throughout
the entirety of Trump's presidency
because the media wanted to scapegoat
somebody for Trump's election and they
couldn't just directly hate on the
American people because that would be
bad for their Optics yeah I think if
anything that might have been born of
people that were born in like the the
area of the Cold War they were they
wanted to blame Russian Russia seemed as
if they were still the Soviet Union when
in reality it's it's far from the case
you know well in remember back in 2012
when Mitt Romney
of course it was Mitt Romney said that
Russia was going to be one of the
primary existential threats to the
United States in coming years and
everyone laughed at him and now
everyone's agreeing with him we should
have kept laughing at him right and I
know people are saying how could you
argue that when Russia is in a hot war
with Ukraine right now part of the
reason Russia is in a hot war with
Ukraine right now is because the United
States has been Reckless and it there's
this idea of speaking softly and
carrying a big stick
what the United States has done is we
have we've spoken very loudly about a
lot of these things when you've spoken
very inappropriately about them what was
interesting about Donald Trump is even
though to some extent he kept the peace
didn't start any new Wars uh Putin
didn't invade while Trump was President
he waited until there was a man with
dementia in the Oval Office before he
decided to invade uh when Trump was in
office there's a good argument he made
that in some sense he was
he was very heavy-handed with Putin in
terms of the threats he made to him at
least according to what Trump has said
what happened was Trump knew that in
order to
guarantee the peace even though
diplomacy was necessary there were
moments where harshness was also
necessary the big red button had to work
and well yeah and there is something
about that and there is something about
the fact that Biden in the left they
either have no idea where those lines
are or they just don't care and I I
suspect it's the latter yeah I think so
they like Trump's had the big stick but
he he spoke loudly but he had the big
stick Biden speaks loudly but he's got a
wet noodle
I think I think there's truth in that
but I also think like it's a depends on
how we're defining speed ing loudly
because even though Trump look he had a
lot of nerve he walked right into North
Korea to meet with Kim Jong-un this is a
guy who while he was being even somewhat
Brash and abrasive was still pursuing
peace like even when he was allowed he
was still pursuing peace he wanted to
find a diplomatic solution to these
problems he wasn't interested in just
going around and bullying other
countries speaking of Peace do you
remember the Kindle I think it's Kendall
Jenner uh ad the Pepsi ad yes
he can goes over to the writers
everyone's happy and love I think all
this Russia talk what we really need is
we need Donald Trump zielinski and Putin
and Trump needs to deliver an ultra
right is that your next commercial I
think so I think we've just developed
that on air
have you noticed that it's really hard
to find people to work yes I have and I
think this is a a the result of an eight
so people have said that a lot of people
retired it's like where so uh we have
the racetrack over here Charlestown
Races and they used to have a restaurant
we asked them how come there's no
restaurant at the horse track anymore
and say we can't find anybody to work
everybody retired they say we can't open
any more poker tables we got no dealers
where'd the dealers go they were they
were tired where are the people who are
working they say nobody's working
anymore the younger generation won't
work 100 imagine what it's going to be
like in this country in 20 years it's
gonna be bad my kids are going to rule
the roost because they will work
a bunch of leftists who won't work are
going to show up with pitchforks and see
all their stuff yeah there's that
usually you end up conscripting people
if you have a society of uneducated or
unemployed uh what just leads you to
desperation which means you can script
them into the military to do some crazy
aggressive conquering War to get the
resources that you weren't producing
these kids today are not doing any
conquering of anything to be clear the
ones that are not working
and it depends right because when
there's a shortage of people
you can't afford war in quite the same
way you look at what's happening in
China I think that's far more concerning
they had a policy of aborting young baby
girls and then also engaging in open and
fanticide and so now the men
have a lopsided ratio there are more men
there by women by a non-insignificant
margin so what do we have we have a
bunch of young men who there are no
women for what do we do with them you
know the United States talks a lot in
our our politicians talk a lot about the
quote-unquote like in-cell problem
they have an entire population of people
for whom there literally are no women
available and everyone knows that
unmarried young men as a demographic are
dangerous so maybe you cook up a word
ago send them to fight and to call that
herd maybe you tell them if you invade
this other country you can have the
women there yeah it's so wild to think
no I'm serious I'm serious
human beings what I mean history did not
end despite what the Marxist or Neo
conservatives whatever you believe I
think people think it's all right this
is this is them there are no these young
people that are not working are not
going to go fight Wars I'm not talking
about here I'm talking about China yeah
I'm talking about any of those places
that's that's that's not happening yeah
I don't know man I I think China is a
serious threat I okay we can talk about
the China thing it's an economic threat
and they're they're winning that threat
that's a whole nother thing they don't
want China doesn't want to attack us
because we're their their cash register
so that's a whole whole another scenario
but I think the problem back to the
young people that don't work there's a
lot of problems there but and that's
that's also in China too like I think
they have Tong ping in China which is
just lying flat which is meaning like
you just they people just don't work
they just don't they literally don't
work thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time